LAURENCE MORONEY: My
name is Laurence Moroney.
I'm a developer
advocate here at Google.
I'm taking a big risk of doing
a talk with a brand new Linux
laptop.
So I've been having some tech
challenges here on the podium,
particularly with
screen resolution.
So bear with me if any of the
demos go a little bit awry.
So I'm a developer
advocate here at Google
I focus on a technology called
Google Play services primarily
and Google Play services
if you're not-- actually,
who's familiar with
Google Play services?
OK, most of you.
So then I don't need to go
into too much detail on it.
But basically,
it's a way that we
have of shipping the runtime
for various Google backend APIs.
And it's something that we
update roughly every six weeks
so that we're not going
Android release cycles.
We can go much faster than the
typical Android release cycles.
And we ship via the Play
Store, that kind of thing.
So I've been a developer
advocate at Google
for about two years.
Prior to that, I did a
lot of mobile development,
freelance mobile development,
including quite a few mapping
apps on the iOS platform and
on the Windows Phone platform.
And it was an
interesting experience.
And what I'm trying
to bring today
is like having used Google Maps
through Google Play services
and having built various
mapping applications,
I wanted to come up with a
set of tips for various things
that you may not realize that
will really, really improve
the perf of your maps.
And as perf matter is
the theme of the show,
hopefully some of these
will be useful to you.
I'm an author.
I've authored 20-ish-- I've lost
count-- of computer programming
books, primarily on
the Microsoft platform.
But forgive me for that.
And about two years ago,
I got into writing novels.
And this is a shameless
self-plug of my newest one,
which is coming out next month.
And I'm the host of a show
called "Coffee With A Googler"
on the Google
Developers channel.
Anybody watch that?
Nice, thank you, thank you.
So that's basically
where what I like to do
is just grab a Googler, sit
down, have a coffee with them,
and talk about what they do,
why they do it, how they do it,
and just try and lift a
little bit of the veil that's
around Google so that you guys
can see that we're just normal
guys, normal
developers like you,
where we love this
technology, and that's
why we do what we do.
So the agenda today
is just really talking
about location
aware applications,
and looking at some
of these 10 tips
around building better apps.
Build better apps
is a mantra that
Magnus-- if you're
familiar with him--
and he came up with, the really
why we do what we like to do.
So we really want to help
you guys build better apps.
It's very easy to build
mobile applications.
It's very hard to build really
good mobile applications.
And it's a journey.
And it's a journey towards
making them and trying
to improve them in
any way you can.
And no matter how
good your app is,
I think there's always
ways to improve it.
And we're always here to learn
from you, just as hopefully,
you can learn from us.
And with some of these 10 tips,
some of them may apply to you.
Some of them may not.
So your mileage may vary.
OK, tip number one.
And this one
actually blew my mind
when I started trying to think
of some of the new things.
And number one is like with
Android Studio, if you've
refreshed it and
brought it up to date,
there's a new Google
Maps activity template
that ships in Android Studio.
And for me, I've
been building maps
with Google Maps for Android
for a year, two years.
And I got to the stage where
I always bypassed the wizard.
And I just rolled my own maps.
And I rolled my own
apps that use maps.
And if you do that,
you may remember
that you've got to go to
the developers console.
And you've got to
register your app.
You got to remember the
namespace for your Android app.
You got to turn on the APIs.
You got to get an
API key for it.
Oh, sorry, I forgot.
You got to get the SHA-1 key
for your development machine
first, right?
And then you've got to go back.
And it's all these
ugly steps that you've
got to go through, all
these hoops that you've
got to go through just to
get an API key so that you
can build a mapping app.
And it's not necessary.
It's a lot of
friction, particularly
for new developers.
But it's one thing that we've
really improved, I believe,
in the new Android Studio.
And the idea is that if
you use the Maps template,
you get an XML file.
It's called mapactivity.xml
or something like that.
And it looks a
little bit like this.
And if you can see in the
comments at the top there,
there's a URL.
And that URL is generated
dynamically for you
based on your app.
And it remembers the namespace.
It gets the SHA-1 key,
all that kind of stuff.
You paste that URL
into your browser.
You get your API key back.
You paste your
API key into that.
And you're done.
So all those ugly hoops
that I was talking about,
all that stuff that
gave people like me
a job teaching you had
to do it has now gone.
And who's familiar with Udacity?
You guys, anybody use Udacity?
Oh, wow, a lot of you.
It's really cool.
I love Udacity.
And I've done a maps
course on Udacity.
And the maps course had
three modules in it.
And most of the first
module is teaching you
how to jump through
all those hoops.
So it's a lot of time that
I had to spend recording it.
But more importantly,
it's a lot of time
that you guys have to
spend watching it in order
to figure out how to
jump through these hoops.
But thankfully,
this new template
that ships with Android Studio
takes all that complexity away
from you and gets you
quicker at producing maps.
And when I'm talking
about perf, I'm not just
talking about runtime perf.
I'm talking about developer perf
as well, your own performance.
And hopefully this will
get you into using maps
a lot more quickly, a lot more
easily, and a lot more friendly
so that you can focus
on what you're doing.
OK, tip number two is to
think about lite mode maps.
Now, it's all very easy to put
a map into your application.
But I've seen applications,
I'll give one example.
It was for a sports
complex near where I live.
And they had this application.
And they asked me how can they
make this application faster.
Some of their users had
been complaining about it.
And they had a map in
the application which was
directions to where they are.
And that's all the map did.
But they had the full map in
there with all of the controls
and all the panning and zooming
and all that kind of stuff.
And they used the full control.
And it took them time
to develop for that when
most of the
functionality that that
gives you for all that extra
weight, they never used.
So it's a common mistake that
developers make because they're
not aware of Lite Mode maps.
And we have lite mode maps now.
It shipped a few months
back for Google Maps.
And if you follow this URI,
you can learn about it.
But the idea is
that you trade off
a little bit of the
interaction in favor
of having a much lighter
map within your application.
And some of the things that
are available to you-- sorry,
I can't see my slides
because of my screen issue.
So I have to keep turning back.
Just one sec.
Like some of the things that
are available to you is-- going
back to the sports app,
this sports complex app
that I was talking
about, one thing
that they really wanted
to do was, OK, well,
if you can touch on the map,
then can it navigate from where
you are now to get to us.
Like if you want to come skating
with us, how do you get there?
So guess what?
Lite maps will
actually give that.
You can launch an activity.
And you can launch a viewer
directions request from that.
So you don't lose that
by going to lite maps.
All the different types--
normal, satellite, hybrid,
all that kind of
stuff-- are still
available within lite maps.
If you like to draw on
your map, like maybe draw
a circle around the
area that you cover
or draw polylines for whatever
you would draw, like maybe
a territory that
you cover as well,
these are still also available.
Projection is still
included in API maps.
And by that, what I mean is
that's calculating the latitude
and longitude offset based on
the pixels on the map itself,
rather than just the
pixels on the screen.
Location is supported.
So if you're using
location on your phone,
you can still plot the
location on the map.
It has partial marker support.
This is one of the trade-offs.
If you build an
application where
you want people to be able
to drag markers around,
drop them in different places,
and customize them at runtime,
lite mode is not for you.
But if you just
want to plot markers
on a map which are
static, then you
don't have to trade
that off if you're
going to use lite mode maps.
And same partial camera support.
There's some nice
little applications--
if you watched my
Udacity course,
you probably saw where I
built one application where
you could fly from Dublin to
Tokyo in about two minutes.
Would that be really nice?
Or from Tokyo to
Dublin and back.
And it was this
beautiful panning
that the camera can
do around the Earth,
showing the Earth
flying underneath you,
all that kind of stuff.
Unfortunately, you can't do that
type of thing with lite maps.
You'd still need to have
the full Google Maps
experience to be able to
take advantage of that.
But if you're thinking
about your application
and if you're thinking
about you just
need a basic map
in your application
that maybe has some polylines,
maybe has some markers,
but you still need to maybe
launch out the navigation,
lite mode maps
will work for you.
And it's much, much lighter.
And it will perform a lot
better within your app.
OK, so tip number three is
to consider GeoJSON or KML.
Now, anybody using either
of these at the moment?
Nobody, OK.
So for some types
of applications--
and I'm going to
demo one in a moment.
I have an application--
hopefully,
I can get it to work
on this screen-- which
plots all of the earthquakes
that happened on Planet Earth
in the last 24 hours.
And what happened is
the US government,
the USGS, has provided
a feed in GeoJSON
of basically those
earthquakes, including
the latitude and longitude, the
magnitude of the earthquake,
and all that type of thing.
And because they have formatted
their data in GeoJSON,
the task that I
have as a developer
to actually build a map to
plot that is insanely easy.
Now, consider that if you're
building an application that
maybe needs to plot a lot
of pins on a map, how would
you do that?
You might have your
server that's generating
these pins dynamically.
And you've probably rolled
your own data format in order
to download that.
And then on the
mobile phone, you
have to write your own parser
to parse that and to plot them.
And we're all smart developers.
That's something
that we can all do.
But have we optimized that
the first time we've built it?
Have we optimized the data
transfer the very first time
we've done it?
Have we optimized the client
for consuming that and plotting
those pins the very
first time we've done it?
The answer is probably no.
And the answer is that
we may have a lot of work
to do to actually build a
client to be able to plot these.
But if on your server side,
you encode these in GeoJSON,
and it's a really
straightforward format,
and then on your
client side, there's
a huge set of utility
libraries, they
will decode the GeoJSON on your
behalf and plot it for you.
And I'll show a quick demo of
an application that does that.
And then I'll show you how
much code on the client side
was required to do this.
So bear with me
while I change out
of presenter mode
on the side screen.
Whoops.
And see if I can
drag the demo over.
Wi-Fi in here has not
been behaving for me,
so it might take a while
for the pins to appear.
And I can't really drag any
further than that, can I?
There we go.
So I'm just running
this in the emulator.
It's hitting the services at
the moment to download the pins.
There we go.
Now the pins are
beginning to appear.
So this is a very
simple application.
I got my map.
I got my standard
controls on my map.
I can zoom into my map.
I see these pins.
These pins are colored based
on the earthquake magnitude.
So we can see a
green pin here was
a magnitude of 1.69 earthquake.
And this blue pin was I guess
a magnitude of less than one.
So the amount of lines of
code to actually do this,
it's about two lines of
code to consume the GeoJSON
and to plot it on a map.
And I'll show that
code in a second.
But as you can see,
typical map, lots of pins,
very, very, easy to develop.
Now the URL-- this
is one of those Linux
laptops with a really
large screen resolution.
But the second
screen is not so big.
And we get something like this.
So if I go to the URL,
it should be here.
Or if you want to open
this URL yourself,
you can see a little bit
of what GeoJSON looks like.
Again Wi-Fi here is
not really behaving.
I'll give that a second.
You know what?
I'll come back to it.
But it gives you the idea.
And here's what the code looks
like when I had my GeoJSON URL.
It actually loaded
when I moved it away.
It'll take it a second.
So when I have a GeoJSON URL
and I download the GeoJSON data
into a JSON object from that,
if I'm using the Android Maps
utils libraries,
all I have to do
is create a new
GeoJSON layer, and then
add that layer to my map.
And that's it.
I didn't have to write any
code for parsing out the data.
code for plotting the pins.
And the people who
have written this code
have it written as a V1.
It's an open source library.
You can see all the changes.
And it's continually
being optimized.
So performance of productivity,
if nothing else, it's great.
But I would say also argue
for performance of like
if you need to plot a
lot of pins on your map,
and these pins are
something that your app you
need to generate server side--
Like one application that I
wrote when I was freelancing,
it was for hotel chains.
And each of these hotel
chains had a curated set
of things near their hotel
that they wanted guests
to be interested in.
And that was a set of pins.
It was set at latitudes and
longitudes and a little bit
of metadata about the location.
They had a server that
would spit that out.
And this iPhone application
that I had written,
I had to write a custom parser
to parse that data, to plot it,
to pin it, all
that kind of thing.
I wish back then I had
known about GeoJSON.
And let me drag my GeoJSON over.
I've got to get this out
of full screen first.
And you can see a
little bit what GeoJSON
looks like in the browser.
It's pretty
straightforward JSON code.
So this is the code
that was generated
by the US government's
earthquake service.
And you can see, you have
JSON, where you just say,
it's being generated.
There's a time that was updated.
But ultimately,
there's a latitude
and there's a longitude.
And there's metadata
about the event.
And all I did, loaded JSON
object with this code, created
GeoJSON layer, add the
GeoJSON layer to the map,
and I was done in creating
that mobile application
that we saw earlier that
was plotting these pins.
I think it's pretty cool.
So that was the code
for using GeoJSON.
In addition to that,
there's also KML.
It's a very similar context.
But KML is usually used for
drawing outlines on a map.
So for example,
you may have seen
maps that show the
Googleplex and has
outlines of the actual
buildings in the Googleplex.
And when you go down to them,
then you have different floors.
And you can see what's
on different floors.
Or maybe you see that
in shopping malls.
There's a great
one on Google Maps.
The language KML is
a markup language
that's used to define that.
And again, if on
your server side,
you need to generate some
type of dynamic floor
or outlines on a map, why
not generate it is KML?
And a very similar
kind of thing here,
two lines of code to be able
to apply that to your map,
instead of you thinking in terms
of all the polylines and all
the floors and all
those kind of things
that you'd have to do it.
Makes your life a
little bit easier.
OK, tip number four-- cluster
is not necessarily a bad word.
So this is a map.
Anybody guess what city this is?
I guess you can read it.
There's a train station.
This is the city of
Cardiff in Wales.
And this is where I
went to university.
And I'm getting to go
back there next week.
I'm really excited.
It's one of my favorite
cities in the world.
And when I was
there as a student,
I was a poor broke student.
And there was a Chinese
restaurant with a really cheap
lunch that I absolutely loved.
And it was almost every day
I went there as a student.
So I went on to-- I
won't say which website.
I went onto a website
to start looking
to see if I can find
this Chinese restaurant.
And I did a search for Chinese
restaurants in Cardiff.
And I found three.
And then I went onto
one of them and I
asked to plot it on a
map, and I got this.
All right, can you spot the
Chinese restaurant on this map?
Cardiff is a wonderful city
with lots of restaurants.
But I can almost guarantee
not every one of those dots
is a Chinese restaurant.
There's all kinds
of things there.
There's sandwich bars.
There's [INAUDIBLE].
If you've got sharp eyes,
the dot over on the right,
the rightmost one is
actually in a prison.
And no joke, apparently, it's
one of the best restaurants
in the city.
I'm going to go visit it.
And what it is, it's for
rehabilitating the prisoners.
They give them jobs
as chefs and waiters
and all that kind of stuff.
And people say it's one of the
best restaurants in the city.
I discovered it when I
was looking for something
completely different.
But anyway, so the problem
with a map like this one--
and when I took
this screenshot, I
was using a really
cheap Chromebook.
When I was searching for this,
it's like $100 Chromebook.
And when I have a
map like this, I
can only see a limited
part of the city.
And I've got all these
dots on this map.
And if I pan this map around,
the several dots here,
they have to pan around as well.
If I zoom in and out, the map
has to plot where these are.
And as you can imagine, that
could be very, very slow,
particularly on a
really cheap Chromebook.
And so my experience in using
this was very, very poor.
And here's another example
of when you can cluster pins
together so that the map is
smart enough that it determines
that if there's over a
certain number of pins
in a specific location, instead
of plotting all of those pins,
it will gather those
pins together and plot
one entity instead.
And if you look at this.
This a map of London.
And if you look here.
I believe there's over a
thousand items actually plotted
on this map.
You can see there's four 200's.
There's 100.
There's a couple of 50s.
There's 1,070 items actually
being plotted on this map.
But the number of things being
drawn on the map-- is it nine?
Yeah.
There's nine items.
So if I zoom this map around,
I'm only moving nine items.
And if I zoom in, then
it will replot this.
I mean, I can show
a live demo later
if anybody wants to see it.
I'm having troubles
with the screen,
so I won't to show it now.
But if you've seen clusters
before, if you zoom in,
then it will pick the
location that you're in.
And it will intelligently
cluster them.
But the idea behind that,
first of all, a great user
experience.
But second of all, performance,
because as the user
pans, as the user
zooms around, you're
only moving eight, nine,
ten entities, instead of
1,000 entities, which
I would be moving
if I tried to pan this
map without clustering.
So clustering, not a bad word.
It's a good thing.
I'll skip over the demo
for the time being.
And I'll show the code.
Again, the code is
really, really simple.
If you're reading
your clusters in--
so we provide an object
in the utils library
called a cluster manager.
You create a cluster
manager for your map.
As you can see here, I
have ClusterManager is new,
CustomManager of item,
and just this .getmap.
And then I have cluster items.
And if I store my locations
as a cluster item.
Sorry, if just general, I have
a collection of my locations.
If I create a cluster
item from that location
and then add those cluster
items to the cluster manager
and then render the map,
all of that hard work
of managing the
clusters, of drawing--
is it 200 in this area?
Is it 100?
Is it 50-- of panning and
moving them around, all of that
work is done for me
by the mapping engine.
So again, like I said,
this is something
you could roll yourself.
And you'd roll a V1.
But would it be optimized?
You know, I'm sure there are
some great developers here who
could build something awesome.
But it may not be
optimized at V1.
This is stuff that we've been
working on for some time.
And this will make
your maps faster.
And it will greatly improve
your user experience.
Now, they may not discover a
restaurant in a prison the way
I did.
But at least you'll be able to
really, really polish and make
your mapping apps a lot
more slick when using this.
OK, next one is
consider something
called polyline encoding.
So one of the apps that I
wrote when I was freelancing
was for a company that provides
services for pet owners.
And in some of the major
cities like New York City,
there is a big business
of hiring people
to walk your dog
while you are at work.
But if I hire somebody to
walk my dog when I'm at work,
how do I know they
actually walked my dog?
And so part of this
application-- I
couldn't put a
beacon on the dog.
Maybe some day
that would be good.
But part of this application,
part of the service
was that your dog walker would
then run this application
while they're walking the dog.
You would ask them to walk
in a particular location.
And then it would
plot-- a little bit
like you've probably
all seen apps
for managing if you go for a
run or if you go for a bike ride
and you can plot that.
Same kind of thing.
And it would plot the dog walk.
And it would plot when
the dog walk happened.
And you could even plot
when you paused for a little
while you were walking the dog.
And you could figure out why you
would pause for a little while
while you're walking a dog.
And all this type of thing was
very valuable to the subscriber
because now they can
see that this money they
paid to a dog walker, the
dog really was being walked.
Now, when you map
a route like that,
you generate a lot of data.
And I'll give one data here.
This isn't a dog walk.
This is a bike ride.
This is a bike ride
that my wife and I
did about three weeks ago.
And we did this
26-mile bike ride
on the east side of Seattle.
And I took a look at the
data dump for this bike ride.
And it was 3,008 data
points were collected
when I did this bike ride.
So the data points that were
collected were the longitude ,
the latitude, the time,
the speed I was going
at, the elevation, all
that type of thing.
And the service that
provides these data points
would give me an XML dump.
And I downloaded that XML dump.
And I took a look at it.
And it was 1.3
megabytes of data.
That's a lot of data.
Now, to be fair on
the service, they
have a lot more data than
just latitude and longitude.
When I'm drawing the line, all I
want is latitude and longitude.
So a lot of that data,
a lot of that size
is because of really useful
data like speed and elevation
and that type of thing.
But when I took a look at if
I want to just draw a line,
like in my dog
walker scenario, I
did a polyline encoding of my
latitude and longitude data
from this plot.
And my 26-mile bike
ride, 3,008 data points,
when using polyline
encoding was about 30K.
OK, that's a lot less
than 1.3 megabytes, right?
And so if you're building an
application that does something
like my dog walker or
plots anything on a map
and you need to store that data,
consider polyline encoding.
I'm not going to go
into the algorithm now.
It's quite an
involved algorithm.
But it basically turns the
latitude and longitude numbers
into-- it string encodes them.
It ASCII encodes them.
And it takes about
eight to 10 bytes
per latitude-longitude
pair to be able to do that.
And that's where I came with
30K for 3,000 odd points.
I'm just rounding it
to 10 bytes per one.
The URL here-- sorry
if it's hard to see.
But I'm sure the
slides will be shared.
We do actually have, on
the Google Maps website,
the polyline encoding
algorithm is there.
But guess what?
You don't need to
write it yourself
because we've
written it for you.
So if you want to
get set of data
and you want to polyline
encode it, you can do so.
So on your server,
for example, you
could polyline encode
something like this,
so it's 30K instead
of 1.3 megabytes.
And then on your
client, you're going
to download that 30K
string and the libraries
will decode that for
you into a set of points
that you can then plot
on a map like this.
So again, great
perf improvements.
You don't need to write
all this for yourself.
You don't need to store all
this type of data for yourself.
And just use the libraries
that are out there.
And again, as I've been saying,
they're optimized for you.
So here's my favorite map again.
And tip six is really
around curated locations.
So one of the things
that I've found
that provides great value
in-- I spoke a little bit.
I created a hotels app
that had mapping in it.
And one of the things
that was of great value
to our customers,
the hotels, was
that instead of a blind API
call to something like a places
API that just throws a bunch
of places at the user that
have been generated
by Google's algorithm,
it was much better for
the customer experience
for something curated.
So the concierge of the hotel
has tried this restaurant
and loved it.
We want to tell that
to our customers.
He's been to this museum,
and it was awesome.
We want to tell that
to our customers.
So there's a dichotomy between
having a pure, just curated set
of content, or having
something that's API driven,
so you can take advantage of
the universe of information
that Google API's
can give to you.
Well, there's also a happy
medium in between them.
And this happy
medium is, go ahead,
build your curated content,
store it in a local database
so it's fast.
The user doesn't
need to be connected
or anything like that.
But guess what?
These locations in the
places API have an ID.
So why not just store that ID
in your local database as well
and get the best of both worlds?
So now for example, I
go to my hotel scenario.
Best 10 restaurants within
a mile of the hotel.
The hotel has picked please.
The hotel might
have a relationship
with these that will
give you a coupon
or have pictures that they've
taken of these restaurants.
But for the user
experience, you can also
use the places ID to
call the places API,
and to get back information
that Google provides
about that place, such as
reviews, such as a Street
View, so you can see what
the restaurant looks like,
such as the online menu,
and everything that would
be available in Google Reviews.
So a great way to really
optimize your maps or location
experience for you users is to
curate, curate, curate, and use
the places API smartly.
This map of my future
visit to Cardiff
was an example where
the places API really
wasn't used that smartly.
It was like, this guy's looking
for a Chinese restaurant.
Let's plot everything
that's associated
with food within a two-mile
radius of his hotel.
And this really doesn't
help me because there's
no way I'm going to click
on every one of those dots
to check out that restaurant.
OK?
I ended up finding
the prison one
that I've been joking about just
because it was off by itself
on the right-hand side.
OK, location and sensor
optimization is our next one.
Now, if you're using location
services on your phone,
guess what, it can
eat your battery.
With Android, we have this
thing called the Fused Location
Provider that allows you to pick
different levels of location
access.
The top most level is
you're using the GPS,
you're using the radio,
you're a Wi-Fi signal,
using lots of other sensors to
be able to determine location.
But of course, the more
accurate, the more expensive
it can be on battery life.
So you really, really be
careful and really optimize
how you're using the
location services.
First of all, you don't always
need to turn them on on start
up.
One thing that we've noticed
when working with apps
and when looking at
apps a lot of the time
is, as soon as the app opens,
boom, I need to use location.
And there's one app that I've
used for when I ride my bike.
And that's what it gave me.
And I'm like, I'm in my garage
pumping up the tires of my bike
right now.
And I open the app.
Why do you need my location now?
How often are you going to
be pinging the GPS to be
able to get my location now?
It might be 20 minutes before
I actually start riding.
So think about, as you're
building for location, starting
at the appropriate time.
With activity recognition
on your phone,
you can get really
smart about that.
You don't even need
to-- I mean, you'll
ping the user for permission
to use location services.
And in Android M, we
do that at the point
that the location service
has been accessed,
rather than when the
app is first installed.
But once you've done that,
you can start using something
like activity recognition.
Say, OK, Laurence is
now riding his bike.
Let's start pinging
for location services.
Doesn't always have
to be at start up.
And it's a common
mistake that we see.
Secondly, a lot of times
for good user experience,
you turn on your
location services.
You open a map.
And then you wait.
And you wait for
like a few seconds
maybe, or maybe a little bit
longer, for it to actually plot
where you are right now.
There is a little
used and really cool
getLastKnownLocation
on the location API.
And what that will do is
that the last known location
that you're at.
It may not always be right.
It may not always be
where you are now.
Particularly if
you travel a lot,
it's kind of funny where it's--
I might open an app that using
getLastLocation.
And I live in Seattle.
And it will show me I'm
in Seattle until location
initializes properly
and then say, actually,
you are in Dallas.
So it doesn't always work great.
But in some scenarios
it works really,
really well to just get your
user into using the location
and seeing where they are,
and then maybe, for example,
seeing restaurants or whatever
around them very quickly.
And it's something that's
really worth investigating
for a great user experience.
Maintaining a best
estimate is also
something that's really good.
When you receive location
updates from the Fused Location
Provider, there can be
random noise in there.
You've probably seen
some applications where
it's showing your bike ride.
And you're going.
And you're like this,
you're like this, like this.
And then there's
one point over here.
And then you're
back in like this,
and like this, and
like this again.
And what that
application is doing
is that's just receiving
updates and plotting them
without really thinking about
them, without doing anything
smart.
There's good things in there
for maintaining a best estimate.
We've provided some code.
It's on the Google
Developer site
for smartly maintaining a
best estimate like that.
I'd strongly recommend to
go and take a look at it.
And then secondly, to
adjust the Fused Location
Provider as needed.
I mentioned before, there are
different tiers of the Fused
Location Provider.
And you can change
them on the fly.
And again, if you're
building an application that
needs to plot your GPS
location every few seconds
like for a bike
ride, it's pretty
obvious you need to keep
it on the highest level.
But maybe you're not building
an application that does that.
Maybe you're building
an application,
for example, that says, find the
nearest coffee shops near you.
You turn on the Fused Location
Provider to the highest level.
You find out where you are.
And then you turn
it right off again.
Or you turn it down.
That type of thing.
It's a really,
really powerful tool.
But like any powerful tool,
you have to use it wisely.
So remember, the
higher the sensitivity,
the higher the cost.
And your users don't like it
if you spend their battery
life flippantly.
A bad habit that people do is to
use overlays to segregate data.
And you've got to
be really, really
careful when using overlays.
So for example, in the
earthquakes example
that I showed earlier on, there
were different colored pins
for different magnitude
of earthquake.
And there's an argument
for you to put each
of these on a different layer.
So then, from the user
experience point of view,
you could say, OK,
turn off the layer
of low magnitude
earthquakes so I can just
see the high magnitude ones.
Or vice versa, that type
of thing, so the user
has this really nice experience.
And it's very easy
for you to develop
because turning layers on
and off is very, very simple.
But you've got to be
really, really careful when
using layers and overlays
like this because if you think
about it, there's 20 different
types of earthquake magnitude,
and I now have 20
different layers,
and I'm using a
low powered device,
if I start dragging
my map around,
I'm replotting 20
different layers.
And each of those pins
and each of those layers
has to have its relative
coordinates plotted based
on its latitude and
longitude, and perf
can be killed as a result.
So my recommendation would
be unless you absolutely
have to use layers, avoid
using too many of them.
Great examples of layers you
probably see in Google Maps,
like traffic is a good layer.
So I like when I'm using Google
Maps that I don't see traffic
until I ask for it.
And then I turn on
the traffic layer.
And if I'm dragging
my map around
to see my location, say,
from here to the airport,
then I understand that I'm
getting a perf hit because
of all this extra data.
But I've asked for
this extra data.
So I definitely
recommend that when
you're using overlays,
just be very, very
careful about using them.
Design your application sensibly
so that the number of overlays
that you are using is really
based on what the user needs.
And don't forget to give your
users the option, of course--
like in the case of the
traffic one- to turn
overlays on and off.
OK, tip nine, using beacons.
And the demo gods haven't
really been with me today.
So I can't really demo this.
But how many of you
have used beacons?
Oh, wow.
A lot of you.
Cool.
So beacons, I find,
are a lot of fun.
I have a few Estimote Beacons
up here on stage with me.
And one of the things that
with beacons is that sometimes
a lot of the samples that
I've seen with beacons
and a lot of the methodologies
are unnecessarily complicated.
And they can be quite
difficult for the user
as well as for the developer.
Let me give an example.
I've seen a scenario
where beacons
could be used at a bus stop.
So you put a beacon
like this on a bus stop.
And you write an
application for your phone,
so that when your
application is open
and it's sniffing
for the beacons
and it gets the idea
of this beacon and then
it knows which bus
stop that you're at,
and then it will give
you a bus schedule
for buses at that bus stop.
Great, right?
Any of you see the drawback?
Trick question.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LAURENCE MORONEY: I wasn't
thinking of that one.
But yeah, that is a good one.
And the sticky on
this isn't very good.
They keep falling off.
But more, it's a case of this
broadcasts a unique namespace
and ID anyway.
So why do I need to register?
I can just sniff that
namespace and ID at any point.
And I can build an
application that's
based on sniffing
that namespace and ID.
And in Google, a few
weeks back, we actually
ran a competition for
people to build applications
based on beacons.
And for the competition-- I won
a prize in the competition--
I came up with the idea of
virtualizing these beacons.
So instead of
thinking of a beacon
in terms of absolute
sense, like this beacon is
at this particular bus stop
and needing to register
and having that
kind of thing, there
are scenarios where you
want beacons anywhere
to be used to be
able to do something.
Now, that sounds very vague.
So let me give you an example.
What I wrote was a game.
And my game was a virtual
tour around some locations.
So I had these three locations.
I work in Google Kirkland.
I had these three beacons
around Google Kirkland.
And I knew the ID
of these beacons.
And I built a little server
side application that said,
the beacon with this ID
is in the barista cafe.
The beacon with this ID
is in-- I can't remember.
It was in registration.
And the beacon with this ID
is in such-and-such a meeting
room.
And then, when somebody played
the game, the idea of the game
was that there's this
animated character who talks
to you through cyberspace.
I have a picture of her here.
There's a bunch of videos, these
CGI videos that are on YouTube,
of her talking to you.
And she's guiding you, saying,
can you go to this location.
And then the location is
what's printed at the bottom.
In this case, it was
Building B Barista.
And then you got to go
there and play a game.
And then she tells you
to go to the next one.
And you go there
and play a game.
But the idea is that by
virtualizing the beacons,
anybody could take any set of
three beacons anywhere-- maybe
bus stop beacons,
or maybe beacons
around the conference
center here-- and turn that
into the same game.
You didn't have to be playing
it in Google Kirkland.
And that's the concept
that I'm talking about when
I say to virtualize beacons.
It's really, really powerful.
Another great example if
you're building for customers
would be, for example,
department stores.
So there are Macy's.
There is one just across
the road here in the mall.
There's one near where I live.
Big department stores
like Macy's, instead
of you registering a particular
beacon in a particular Macy's
location somewhere, you could
say the beacon of this ID
is in the Menswear
in Macy's in Dallas.
Another one is in the Menswear
in Bellevue in Washington.
That type of thing.
So then when you use
location services to say,
oh, this user is in Washington.
He or she is in Bellevue.
And let's start sniffing
the beacons that we can see.
Ah, I've matched this
beacon against the Menswear.
And now I'm able to give
an experience for Menswear
in Macy's.
That type of thing.
So virtualizing
beacons can actually
be really, really powerful.
I'm going to open source
that game if anybody
wants to-- email me if you
want to take a look at it.
It's a whole lot of fun.
I hired a professional actress
to voice this character.
It's really cool.
I'll see if I can run it
on my phone in a moment.
But the Wi-Fi hasn't
been behaving.
So tip 10 we're on to next.
A lot of the tips that I've
been talking about today
actually are part of this.
We have a thing called
the API utility library.
If you build anything
to do with maps,
I strongly recommend you
go and download this today.
Download the samples
for this today.
Dissect this today.
Because a lot of the hips
that I've been going through
have been encapsulated
in APIs that are in this.
So GeoJSON and KML that I spoke
about are available in this.
So your decoders for
Android are in there.
Heat maps are something
I haven't spoken about.
But if you want to plot a heat
map around a particular area,
like thunderstorms.
I hear the thunderstorm
is coming tonight.
So if you wanted,
instead of just plotting
pins for thunderstorms
based on the concentration
of thunderstorms in
a particular area,
to actually build
a heat map, which
would give the user a
better-- or the earthquakes
is another one--
to give the user
a better feeling of what is
really happening with the data.
Heat maps are great.
You can customize
your markers instead
of just the usual regular pins.
You can customize them and have
a whole lot of fun with them.
Clusters, which is probably
my single favorite feature--
if you've ever built
any map applications,
clusters are really your friend.
All that cluster manager
stuff is in there.
The polyline encoding
that I spoke about,
so the libraries to turn
latitude and longitude
into a few bytes so that you
can store, decode them, make
your life a lot
easier is in there.
Things such as calculating
distance between two points.
It's not really a
straight line because
of the curvature of the earth.
Things like that, those type
of distance calculations
are in there.
Area of a location, same thing.
When you think about
curvature of the Earth as well
as contours, that's in there.
Heading calculations
are in there.
And it's all open source.
And there's a really
teeny tiny URL there.
Sorry about that.
Hopefully, when those
slides are shared,
you'll be able to see them.
But wait, there's more.
And good-- what's the word?
Commercial sense, anyway.
What are those late
night commercials?
What are they called?
AUDIENCE: Infomercials.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Infomercials, thank you.
In good infomercial
sense-- wait, there's more.
So there's lots of other
great stuff with maps
that I didn't have
time to fit in.
Maps on Android Wear is
something that we shipped.
So you can actually have a
little map on your watch,
like great for
navigation applications,
that type of thing.
And there's something called
ambient mode, which turns it
down into a low contrast map, a
very dark one, when you're not
moving your watch around
to save battery life.
The camera, to play
with the camera
is really interesting to
create very dramatic scenarios.
There are 3D plots you may
have seen on Google Maps.
And when you combine those 3D
plots with satellite imagery,
you can create really
interesting, fun,
beautiful fly-arounds of cities.
And again, they perform
really, really well.
Street View, also known in
my opinion as Best Tech Ever.
OK?
Street View was
the tech that made
me fall in love with Google.
And I tell this
story all the time.
And this is a true story.
And earlier on at the
beginning of the presentation,
I said I write books.
And I wrote this
book back in 2011.
And it was a science
fiction book, most of which
was based in the Navajo
reservation in New Mexico,
and some of which was based
in a small town in Japan
just outside of Nagasaki.
And after the book
was published,
within the same week,
coincidentally enough,
I received two emails
from readers-- one
from the town in New Mexico
that the book is based.
It's called Shiprock.
And one from Omura in Japan.
And they said, we love the book.
It's so cool that our
town was in this book.
This is fabulous.
When did you visit?
You know, when did
you write this book?
If you ever come back,
let's grab a coffee together
or something like that.
This is fabulous.
And I was like, I've never
been to either of those towns.
And I did everything
using Street View.
You know, I'd open
up Street View
and I walked around the town.
And one of the
scenes in this book
is in the high
school in Shiprock.
And apparently, I nailed
it, what it looks like.
And I was like, I've
never even been.
I'd love to go someday.
But it was all thanks
to Street View.
That's why I love Street View,
to me, AKA Best Tech Ever.
And think about the things
that you can do for your users
by having Street
View in your apps.
Marker visualizations, custom
markers I've mentioned already.
Sorry.
Another one is geofencing.
Anybody build anything or
familiar with geofencing?
Oh, cool.
Nice.
So geofencing, the
idea is you can
pick a latitude and longitude.
You can define a
radius around that,
and generate an alarm when
something enters or exits
that area.
And I used to have this
app that I used at home
and my family still use it, so
that when my daughter started
driving, we asked that she
use this app so that we
could know where she is.
But one of the
downsides of this app
was that whenever she
came home and went
through the geofence
for home, a sound would
play on everybody's phone.
Now, my dog got to associate the
sound with my daughter coming
home.
And my dog loves my
daughter to bits.
So he would hear the
sound on the phone.
And he'd go crazy.
He would go run to the garage.
And bang, bang, bang,
bang on the door,
so we could open the
garage so he could go out
and he could greet my
daughter coming home.
And so one day as
an experiment, I
decided to get the wave file
of the same sound and play it.
Poor dog went nuts.
My daughter wasn't home.
I opened the garage.
He had to run out to the garage.
He had to run around the
garage, that kind of thing.
And it took a
little while for him
to be satisfied that she
wasn't actually there.
At that point, I was tempted
to play the sound again.
But I'm not that cruel.
So some of the
scenarios that can
be enabled by geofencing I just
think are really, really cool.
You can trick your dog with it.
Or you can build applications
that are good for families
or whatever using geofencing.
And one thing that I
actually built once
was a virtual reality
game that used geofencing.
So once you ran into a
particular area, then
you have augmented
reality in that area.
And then you have to do things
within augmented reality.
It was a whole lot of fun.
And then finally, the activity
recognition that I mentioned.
The activity
recognition APIs, they
will give you back a
percentage likelihood
that you're doing something.
They're not entirely
100% accurate.
They will say, hey, at
this moment in time,
there's a 20% chance
that you're running,
but you're probably
standing still.
That type of thing.
So it takes a little
bit of working
with them and a little
bit of intelligence
to be able to use them
very, very accurately.
But they are pretty good.
OK, so contact.
My Twitter is I'm at @lmoroney.
If you've any questions for
me, it's lmoroney@google.
On Plus, I'm
+laurencemoroney, or Facebook,
it's
facebook.com/laurence.moroney.
With that, thank you.
Sorry for the few technical
hiccups that we had.
And if anybody
has any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]